bigquery is Google's fully managed  terabyte scale locos analytics data  warehouse let's see how to use bigquery  with C sharp first make sure the API is  enabling your project a service account  exist to make API calls and proper  access control is setup for bigquery all  are explained in the cobweb in the video  notes in class shell let's create a  simple dotnet console app and add  bigquery API nougat package to the  project open the online code editor and  navigate to program dot C s we will  query a sample table called Shakespeare  it contains the number of times each  word appears in each work of Shakespeare  let's count the total number of each  word reference to beaker library create  a big query client and get the table  that we are interested in  construct the sequel to [ __ ] the words  and execute the query finally print two  results let's run the app there you go  you just use bigquery with c-sharp